bonsoir jean marc jancovici soir merci à
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoints sur ce
plateau vous êtes expert en questions
climatiques vous avez notamment écrit
transition énergétique pour tout ce que
les politiques n'ose pas vous dire chez
odile jacob donc vous allez nous dire
directement parce que ce rapport du giec
aujourd'hui il est très alarmiste il
évoque l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique de la montée des eaux
mais quelle valeur at il par rapport à
tous ceux qui doutent un peu de cette
accentuation du réchauffement climatique
le doute est toujours quelque chose qui
est normal face à quelque chose qu'on ne
comprend pas et par ailleurs les gens
qui doutent vous savez que certains ont
des raisons légitimes de douter et
d'autres moins légitime alors qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un rapport du giec
c'est une tentative de résumer très
compliqué très long et quasiment
inaccessible pour le commun des mortels
de tout ce que la science a raconté sur
le sujet depuis en fait qu'il existe des
recherches qui se penche sur l'influencé
de l'homme sur le climat
donc vous avez des centaines de milliers
de pages publiées dans des revues
scientifiques ni vous ni moi ne sommes
capables de les dire et le monde
scientifique s'organise pour faire un
guichet unique de mise à disposition de
l'information en résumant comme il le
peut ces centaines de milliers de pages
en 800 pages
donc ça peut être sujet à
interprétations où ça une valeur
scientifique incontestable
alors ça une valeur scientifique
incontestable c'est quelque chose qui
est fait dans les mêmes règles que toute
littérature scientifique c'est à dire qu
un chercheur d'ibm voilà ce que je pense
il le soumet à ses pairs qui disent on
est d'accord tu t'es trompé
là on pense que etc et une fois que il
ya une manière consensuelle d'exprimer à
la fois les certitudes et des
incertitudes c'est publié on avait parlé
d'une pause climatique
or ce rapport il évoque et
l'accélération du réchauffement et de la
montée des eaux
je comprends quand c'est quelqu'un qui a
de la fièvre il peut avoir
transitoirement un tout petit peu moins
de fièvre pendant une minute une heure
et pourtant ne pas être guéri là c'est
exactement pareil si vous choisi si vous
choisissez pardon très soigneusement la
date de début et la date de fin depuis
le début du 20e siècle
vous avez six ou sept épisodes ou sur
dix ans vous avez l'impression que la
température n'augmente plus voilà c'est
s'est pas particulièrement significatif
parce que le supplément d'effet de serre
qui réchauffe les basses couches de
l'atmosphère
il va pour partie chauffer l'atmosphère
est pour partie chauffée l'océan et
selon que il chauffe un peu plus l'océan
un peu moins l'océan la température de
l'air peut monter un peu plus vite un
peu moins vite ou même ne semblait plus
montée du tout pendant dix ans tout ça
ne valide pas le fait que globalement ça
chauffe donc aujourd'hui globalement ça
chauffe ça chauffe beaucoup et ce
rapport il évoque la responsabilité
essentielle fondamentale de l'homme et
une fois de plus comment est ce qu'on le
prouve
précisément alors il faut savoir que
l'effet de serre c'est quelque chose qui
est connue depuis un siècle et demi on
doit ça un physicien français fourier
qui a dit il ya un siècle et demi que ça
existe oeil qui a expliqué du reste
n'ont d'autres physiciens ont expliqué
peu après par don que c'était dû à la
vapeur d'eau et au co2 dont on sait ça
depuis très très longtemps
ce qu'on sait depuis beaucoup moins
longtemps c'est que quelques degrés de
variation de la moyenne planétaire
c'est ce qui sépare une ère glaciaire du
climat qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc en fait on ne sait que depuis
quelques dizaines d'années que c'est
quelque chose d'absolument massif et qui
serait très très destructeur pour des
civilisations installés ici est par
ailleurs sédentaires et ayant l'habitude
d'une certaine forme d'abondance que le
changement climatique remettrait en
question
c'est ça qu'on sait depuis pas très
longtemps et c'est ça qui rend le
problème particulièrement angoissant et
donc ils donnent envie un certain nombre
de gens de dire bah non ça n'existe pas
comment ceci comment vous en explique
les différentes augmentations de
température que donne ce rapport ça va
jusqu'à plus de 4 degrés de
réchauffement mais ça peut être bien
inférieur
comment est-ce qu'on peut éviter le pire
alors il ya deux grandes sources
d'incertitudes
la première c'est que le comportement
des hommes n'est pas écrit al avance et
donc selon qu'avait-il vertueux
exactement selon que à partir de
maintenant on va mettre plus ou moins de
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
et pour faire écho au débat qui a en
france sur la transition énergétique
selon qu'on va utiliser plus de pétrole
de gaz et de charbon moins de pétrole de
gaz et de charbon et que les autres font
pareil ou pas eh bien le climat se
réchauffera plus où il se réchauffera -
et puis s arrêtant de licence la laddh
le deuxième déterminant c'est que les
espèces de microscopes que les
scientifiques utilisent pour scruter
l'avenir ou de télescopes plus tôt
comporte des imprécisions qui sont
irréductibles
vous savez que quand on cherche à
prévoir la météo pour demain c'est
fiable pour après demain c'est fiable
sur 115 joueurs en 2h15
pour c'est un peu moins fiable donc vous
commencez à avoir des grandes chelsea
aura une dépression ou pas ça vous savez
pas exactement où elle va passer balle
les modèles climatiques c'est pareil
vous avez une partie très robuste donc
l'ordre de grandeur il bon et après vous
avez une forme d'incertitude qui est
pour le moment irréductibles mais cette
incertitude n'invalide pas le fait que
de toute façon il faut l'éviter
dit autrement si vous traversez les
champs elysées à 4 heures du matin les
yeux fermés c'est pas sûr que vous
fassiez tuer pour autant d'étapes
intérêt faire alors les efforts qui sont
faits vous évoquez le plan de transition
énergétique
on l'entend là on entend washington
s'est mobilisée dire qu'il faut
absolument multiplier les efforts les
politiques joue-t-il assez leur rôle
dans cette lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique alors la réponse est non et
c'est pour partie leur faute et pour
partie pas leur faute
le pour patty leur faute c'est que les
efforts que font les politiques pour
comprendre de quoi on parle sont
malheureusement très insuffisant c'est
très difficile d'obtenir un temps
significatif d'un élu dans ce pays pour
qu'il comprenne de quoi on parle là où
c'est qu'à moitié leur faute c'est que
vous savez qu'un élu en démocratie est
censée refléter l'opinion de la majorité
la majorité parfois à des envies
contradictoires donc nous nous avons des
avis contradictoires tout de suite là
une partie des gens qui nous regardent
vous dira pourrait peut-être quand même
faire quelque chose et puis demain ils
vont sans même s'en rendre compte pour
partie faire l'exact inverse de ce qu'il
faudrait faire
et le prime de l'élu c'est d'arriver à
réconcilier ses envies contradictoire
parce qu'on est tous un peu schizophrène
vous vous le savez bien donc pas
suffisant pour jean marc jancovici ce
soir expert en questions climatiques
après le rapport du giec merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur bfm tv